what's the future of the american right
wing
in the united states i know we have an
election coming up
where donald trump may get another four
years he may not get
another four years and certainly that's
going to be a big
part of setting the direction of the
republican party in the united states
for the next few years but my question
is actually more about the future
of the conservative movement or the
american right wing much of which is not
actually conservative which is part of
the discussion we have to have
and the future of the american right
could be through the republican party
or it might not and that's another part
of what i've been thinking about a lot
and
i've said before this part is not new
we're not breaking new ground here
trumpism isn't going to go away when
donald trump leaves the white house that
could be this january it could be
january of 2025.
there's actually a part of the american
right
that wants to get away from trumpism as
quickly as possible and
can't see the day when they finally get
away from trumpism
but you actually right now have an
american right wing
that is more divided than it's been in a
long time
certainly if you compare it to the era
of george w
bush even if you compare it to the era
of when john mccain and mitt romney were
respectively running against
barack obama in 2008 and 2012 the
american right is so
divided right now actually that many
republicans
aren't even going to vote for the
incumbent
republican president this time around
you've got
we just learned today prominent
conservative george will
has announced he sees trump as so
antithetical
to the republican party's values as he
sees them
that he is actually going to vote for
joe biden in november you have groups
like
the lincoln project made up of
well-known republicans who are actively
campaigning against donald trump
under the guise of needing a return to
sanity even though we all
intuitively know as soon as joe biden
gets elected if he does
those republicans instantly go back to
being in the opposition i have no
confusion about
that whatsoever and there are actually
some real questions
about what is the direction that the
american right
wants to go in once donald trump
does leave office now on an issues level
we do see the country moving to the left
if you look at issues like abortion
being legal in most cases
that is more support today than it ever
has since roe v wade
if you look at support of gay marriage
you know other issues like
employers not being able to fire people
on the basis of sexual orientation
more than ever today the country is as
left as it has been on those issues
the country is as least religious as it
has been
since that's something that has been
tracked and the country
understands and trusts in science more
today
than it ever has in the balance with
religion the people who are on the
opposing side are very loud and many of
them are very
loudly in favor of donald trump so that
can skew the feeling
but that is a reality however
even though on abortion and gay marriage
and other issues the country
is more to the left than it has ever
ever been we do have a very divided
country needless to say
it's just a country that's divided um
along different lines
think about 2010 in response to
barack obama winning in 2008 the tea
party movement
surged in 2010 and the tea party
movement
became prominent it was a movement which
focused on
one particular conservative ideology the
sort of reactionary don't tread on me
stuff
which includes so-called liberty like
deregulation and lower taxes for the
rich and it happened to have some really
wacky people in it
people in the tea party who were very
much in contrast
to the more establishment traditional
republicans of the time
mitt romney compared to the tea party
crowd
is not a trivial contrast even though in
2012
2010 they were basically all just voting
for republicans
when some tea party candidates were
elected in the 2010 midterms to the
house of representatives i suggested one
of two things is eventually going to
happen with this movement either
that is just a blip in terms of those
tea party views and they're going to be
pushed back out and they'll be gone from
the republican party
or they'll become integrated into the
republican party and no longer be much
of a separate group
and that's essentially what happened you
do have a tea party caucus in the house
of representatives
it's not very prominent they have 23
seats in the house
modest but not insignificant and some
sort of more libertarian don't tread on
me ideas have infiltrated
the republican party big picture but
it's not dramatically
changed the republican party whenever
trump ultimately leaves
the american right is going to have to
make a decision about the direction they
want to go
the decision is not likely to be made by
some kind of central meeting
it's more likely a decision that's going
to be made implicitly by
who they vote for to be their nominee in
2024
who they vote for in the house who they
vote for in the senate
so some of the questions that come up
are
as an example is there a future in the
republican party
that bridges the sort of mitt romney
pro-business right
the religious right and the liberty
freedom right which
are the three groups that i've
identified previously
with what i am calling the fourth wing
of the right
which is the i i don't want to be
pejorative but it's like the reactionary
anti-intellectuals it's trumpism
essentially and
i don't really know what it should be
called this fourth group
it's a group that doesn't really care
about policy you've noticed that under
trump
it's not a particularly religious group
at least not by definition
but they basically see trump as a genius
and they favor doing things that just
trigger the libs it's not about getting
things done it's not even about policy
it's about being reactionary
and inflammatory and using coarse
language and triggering the libs owning
the libs
is that going to be the direction of the
party
or is that fourth wing going to be
pushed into obscurity
and the future of the mainstream
american right
will remain in the republican party much
like
the left over the last four to six years
has become more about
you know there's been a coalescing of
source health care for everybody
dealing with inequality dealing with
climate are we going to see the right
shift in priorities if the future of the
right
is not through the republican party
where is it
and what does the republican party
become if the future of the american
right
is in the republican party what do they
do about trumpism
because i don't see trumpism becoming
enmeshed in the republican party in the
same way that the tea party
did these are important matters and i
want to hear from you about it and what
i care most about
really is we want to understand this why
it's not just an academic exercise
we want to understand the future of the
american right so that the left can take
advantage of it
we want the chaos on the right whether
the chaos
it starts in january with the
inauguration of joe biden
maybe it doesn't start until later down
the line how can the left
take advantage of the division on the
right and the uncertainty of the
conservative movement
within or outside of the republican
party to get
things done that's the priority it's an
interesting academic and philosophical
exercise but the goal of it is to figure
out what is our strategy for actually
getting things done
which includes by the way as part of the
american left
pushing the democratic party to be more
left than it actually is
we'll continue thinking about it and i
want to hear from you if you've been
watching the show you've probably heard
me talk about how much i love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put in my living room at home
it's now
my favorite piece of furniture in the
house
it took me just minutes to set it up
it's solidly built
it's huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality
it has become the focal point of my
living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get 20 percent off your entire
order when you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video